[Musique]
ça produit qui est tellement beau et à
moi unique
j'aime ce que son crack mais vraiment
les textures ça c'est que sa fronde en
bouche
bienvenue dans le monde merveilleux des
champignons urbain j'ai deux préférés
entre mâles les inaki orange les pieds
au pineau c'est vraiment plus qu'un
champion la texture la saveur à ses
analyses il y actuellement un grand
engouement pour les champignonnières en
milieu urbain le chef michael loyer est
l'un de ceux qui se sont lancés dans
l'aventuré à l'écrit un marché qui
n'était pas nécessairement à montréal
quand as-tu les autres producteurs de
champignons urbain on se connaît tous on
se parle tous sont concentrés pourquoi
ça s'appelle les 400 pi les 400 villes
champignons ça a commencé dans un local
de 400 pieds carrés
on a grandit donc maintenant on est en
dessous de 1500 pieds carrés sont tous
différents sont toutes superbes ni répit
opinion pichichi champignons implanté en
plein quartier résidentiel à laval on
sent aussi un grand vent d'enthousiasmé
c'est peter walker moi c'est annie
fournier et william sont propriétaires
de champignons avec huit arrivées une
journée vieux démons amour on va faire
pousser des champignons j'ai dit mais
j'ai dit est de tomber sur la tête alors
ça a commencé dans le garage au début
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bâtiment
lancé un gazebo qui était venu sans de
production laboratoire laboratoire
cristallisation dix axes et les plus
méritants après son transfert ça dans
l'incubation ces deux productions de
samedi passé à peu près huit sortes de
pleurotes ici qui sont prêtes et nos
quais et king safran de l'équipement
tout ça c'était pas très accessible au
québec il fallait fouiller longtemps
parfois pour trouver des bonnes sources
le bon équipement les bonnes techniques
pour pouvoir et efficace en fait
[Musique]
des champions ça pose sur tout qu'est ce
qui est fait de cellulose sa pause dans
les milieux où ce que la moisissure est
parfaite russie un environnement propre
et stérile bien ventilé c'est une
priorité chez les producteurs de
champignons urbain principalement on
parle d'un champignon frais qu'ils on va
l'intégrer sur un morceau d'agar agar
ont rempli des sacs avec notre soustrot
siècle le substrat peut être composé de
granules de bois des cales de soya ou
d'autres matières végétales
on lit draps on va le stériliser on va
inaugurer notre cistre il va un cube et
trois semaines à deux mois trois mois
par après on va perforer les trous dans
nos sacs puis on va les intégrer dans
nos chambres de culture là on va faire
deux à cinq récoltes par bloc sera ainsi
que de plusieurs semaines on a le
hainaut qui dort et on a le shimmy 10 ou
le beach des kings auster ou des pleurs
hauteur roi dépit au pineau champignon a
maintenant 16 variétés de champignons
quoi la différence vos plus belles
contrées d'épicerie la fraîcheur mai
prochain définitivement ce prix que les
pleurotes de l'épicerie ont déjà une
semaine
moi je vends même pas de champignons
après deux ou trois jours
[Musique]
est ce que c'est la goutte fort ça coûte
pas nécessairement plus fort donc tout
vraiment un profil en bouche qui
complètement différents mais qu'est ce
qu'on va manger champions paris qu un
champignon c'est simple on son prince
champignons plaque prod on va l'écouter
simplement en deux fois un gros pavé
ça va une voile des allemands en fonte
en huile qui a un auto de fumaison on
commence pas avec le beurre on commence
pas avec des lots libres voilà tous les
canaux l'hôtel le végétal gras de canard
bar clarifiée c'est un des gros qui
n'ont pas nécessairement brûlé si le
ferez pas assez fort aussi dans la poêle
les champignons bon cracher leur voix
peu plus puis on va jamais allés
chercher une belle coloration les ide ne
hérisson crinière de lion c'est vraiment
une grosse boule plonge dans la rue leur
choux fleurs c'est excessivement bien en
deux ans par un gros pavé dans un steak
les pleurs à bleu c'est bien craquant
après la cuisson ce que ce forestier
[Musique]
paulette a dit spurs donc un super de
boer champignons ils se mangent de la
tête aux pieds
on va tout simplement les poils et
comment jouer avec un petit 1 en fin de
cuisson ça a l'air super craquant c'est
vraiment un arômes de noisette hoc film
ce champignon délicat avec des notes
boisées et link haut rhin le moins qu'on
bouge un champignon le muc si on va
aller chercher une super de belle
coloration donc c'est bien dorées ont
valu à brasser une fois après deux trois
minutes de cuisson on va recommencer le
processus
quand on a deux beaux côtés bien coloré
on veut diminuer le feu on va acheter
notre noisette de beurre
on va les supports légèrement prenait
revient à créneaux champignons on met le
seul à la fin si on met le sel au début
ils vont tout dégorger l'euro puis après
ça on était le ferons peu déglacer avec
ce fond vos du vin blanc de la bière ce
qu'on veut en finir avec un peu d'huile
d'olive sombre peut manger deux barres
puis on met des aromates échalotes
ciboulette aïe
de là on attend une bonne pour les deux
champions
on va les petits hôpitaux aussi cette
beauté oui c'est cela qui ont une
texture thomas pétanque
c'est fou c'est vraiment vraiment quelle
belle découverte
ça vaut la peine de faire 400 pas prenez
des chercher secteur
[Rires]
[Musique]